this is dave klein reading for mark
delaney i've never envied the
development cycle that comes with
working on an annual sports game series
when you consider how much time and
money goes into any other big budget
project asking a studio to constantly
churn out a game that is both functional
and consistent but also fresh and
exciting every single year seems unfair
nba 2k 23 is incredibly impressive
regardless but even more so in light of
this tight dev cycle with a deep suite
of fun game modes improved encore
gameplay and a deeper social experience
it feels like the team of visual
concepts managed to freeze time and
spend longer than the typical cycle on
this exceptional nba sim
[Music]
it's hard to know where to begin with
nba 2k 23 because in ways both big and
small there's a lot of new stuff to see
for me though it starts with the jordan
challenge for the first time since nba
2k11 you can relive highlights from the
career of the greatest player in nba
history more than just a rehash of a
mode absent for over a decade this
renewed jordan challenge is like a
modern remake of that original concept
beginning in his college career at north
carolina you'll play through 15 of
jordan's biggest games and work to
recreate stat lines and other outcomes
like a time traveler seeking to relive
jordan's forever on replay highlights
conceptually this is as it was before
albeit now with 5 more games than the
original iteration but the finer details
are where the jordan challenge really
shines in 2k 23 era appropriate filters
retro on-screen graphics and even long
gun arenas and fittingly depressed
spectators work together to transport
players to the time and place of each
game spanning the 80s and 90s
before each game the visual concepts
team includes new interview segments
with players commentators coaches and
others who witnessed the greatness of
michael jordan first hand collectively
it gives the whole mode the feeling of
an interactive museum to unrivaled
basketball achievements and playing it
has been the first time in my life that
a sports game gave me goosebumps
not content to only have jordan reside
on the game's figurative memory lane my
nba mode is also infused with many of
these same features including even
throwback teams like the seattle
supersonics these features wouldn't make
sense in a modern setting and so the
game allows you to start your league in
one of three bygone eras across the 80s
90s and 2000s this allows you to
position your team to draft or trade for
the contemporary or incoming stars of
each era and recreate basketball history
from the starting point like creating
alternate realities where lebron james
was drafted by philly or jordan never
retired for two years in the middle of
his prime
the league will change as you go too
with rule books getting updated dominant
play styles changing over the years and
teams relocating or not if you decide
your nba alt universe keeps the sonics
where they belong for example
these two modes represent ways this
year's game feels like it goes above and
beyond other sports sims just aren't
offering this type of content for their
players it's a remarkable thing and
feels handled with care and attention
from a studio that must be full of real
basketball fanatics the love of the game
is pouring out of these two modes and
would merely by themselves qualify nba
2k 23 as a must play for basketball fans
nba 2k has long been a series that
sweats the small stuff too wildly
lifelike player animations best in class
commentary and unmatched broadcast style
presentation all return with impressive
added touches like different commentary
teams depending on which mode you're
playing nba nba2k has a long put some
other sports series
which i won't name but you can probably
guess to shame with such attention to
detail and these little things have an
outsized effect in the end making the
series the most enjoyable sports game
every single year
though the nba itself generally favors
the three ball in real life that's not
the case for all players of course but
last year's game made sharpshooters out
of anyone with an open look it was
unrealistic and altered what is arguably
the most important aspect online pickup
games with friends and rivals 2k 23
focuses largely on giving power back to
the strong finishers and slashers of the
league preventing back-to-back years
where everyone looks like steph curry
modeled after the play of buxford
giannis hadn't compo this year's game
feels better balanced right away for
different play styles those who aren't
natural shooters have regressed to
something more realistic while those who
lean into the paint and bully defenders
now feel just as dominant as a shooter
from behind the arc in turn this has
made online pvp games more enjoyable as
they no longer feel like three-point
contests for many players the heart of
the game is always my player though the
actual narrative of each year's game
varies in quality i found this year's
story to be surprisingly enjoyable in it
you'll land with the team of your
choosing as the 18th overall pick and
nba draft but selected right after you
is shep owens your college rival and the
player your team's fans actually wanted
through months of hard work on the court
and some silly pr campaigns in the city
your job is to win over hearts and minds
sports game story modes like sports
movies can get corny in a hurry but this
year's story manages to defy odds and
land on the right side of the tracks
with its constant attempts at humor i
usually wasn't cringing and was
sometimes even laughing which adds up to
the story better than most in others in
this space perhaps the best part of my
career is how well it integrates right
into the city as the mmo-like live
service hub of the game the city is
where players spend the most hours after
they finish the story knowing that the
team has designed this year's game to
give you narrative reasons for running
around the city completing quests for
dozens of npcs like as an rpg you'll be
winning over districts of fans like a
san andreas turf war but here your
weapons will be charity work endorsement
deals and the occasional viral tweet
after years of the city and its
predecessor of the neighborhood then
mode still feels like an accomplishment
like the jordan challenge and my nba
eras this social hub is something only
nba 2k is doing and helps separate it
from the rest of the pack making it easy
for fans of multiple sports games to
know where to invest their time with
tons of modes and attractions including
a new theater where limited time modes
now reside on a rotating schedule the
city isn't perfect though for those who
don't want to run from quest to court
and vice versa skateboards and bikes are
back but they control so poorly and
always have that i'm more likely to stay
on foot and accept the speed decrease
thankfully now fast travel points have
been added in the form of subway
stations and this year's city is
actually about 30 percent smaller due to
fan demand for a more dense cityscape
still both quest and travel distances
will sometimes call for using
skateboards but they're frustratingly
unwieldy
if you're not new to the series you'll
likely already know how invasive the
microtransactions
mtx are even at its past heights the pay
model has been the thing taking this
series down a peg or two and it's still
an issue here the problem is twofold on
one hand the game's my team mode is just
as bad as any comparable mode such as
ultimate team in ea sports games it's
pay to win without a doubt given how any
player can simply buy up unlimited card
packs until they've landed a dominant
team but the game's mtx continues to
dampen the city too as this same virtual
currency that can upgrade your squad in
my team can also dramatically improve
your my player protagonist too
as that player eventually migrates out
of the story and into the city it causes
a my team-like rift between those who
grind for greatness and those who paid
their way up the ranks it's clear some
percentage of the players may prefer the
game lets them upgrade right away but
then they have to face them in the
city's courts and other pvp modes feels
like getting stuck in a first person
shooter lobby with wall hackers and
aimbotters making it so the same
currency buys tattoos repaints
skateboards and upgrades or player feels
like a long broken feature that the game
just keeps returning to each september
the city is also smothered by product
placement in a way that is so over the
top it would be hilarious if it wasn't
giving me such a dark preview of the
so-called metaverse virtually everything
is a commercial from gatorade and nike
to mobile and nokia it feels like i
can't even high-five a teammate without
it being brought to me by mountain dew
these issues do hinder nba 2k 23 from
being historically great but all else
adds up to what is still an exceptional
basketball game made with an intense
attention to detail and a love of the
game on the court nba 2k 23 looks and
feels lifelike and exciting in every
drive and the new and revamped modes
treat the nba like a revered historical
monument in those important ways it does
its best to reflect jordan's greatness
and shows both nba newcomers and
historians what it's like to play like
mike
[Music]
supposedly jordan wasn't a three-point
shooter how about six in the first half
[Music]
brutal wow